[Music]
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
paid a surprise visit to the recaptured
town of ism on Wednesday a key Logistics
Hub in the northeastern hakib region
[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
thousands of Russian troops fled ISM
over the weekend in Russia's worst
defeat since they were driven back from
the outskirts of Kiev in March zelenski
has vowed to recapture all Ukrainian
territory from Russian forces including
Crimea which was annexed by Russia in
2014.
the viewer is very shocking but it's not
shock for me because we we began to see
the same
pictures from bucha from the first the
occupied territors so the same destroyed
buildings killed people and so
what can I say
that that is the
the part of our real
his story
and the part of
of modern today's Russian Nation
yeah that they did it only them we know
that truth is on our side though so it
means that we will come
I don't know when and nobody knows when
we have plans so we'll come because
because it's our land and it's our
people that's why we'll come yeah
foreign
[Music]
the Ukrainian President also met with
servicemen in the northeastern Ukrainian
town of balaclia which was also
recaptured by Ukrainian troops
because
foreign
[Music]